وتنضم لنا من الرياض ده للفنانه اللبنانيه
ناتاشا ناتاشا اهلا بك يسعد صباحك معانا
في صباح العربيه
صباح الخير عليكم كلكم وتانكيو كتير على
الانترودكشن الحلوه اااه صباح الخير لكل
مشاهدين العربيه ولكل متابعين يلي عم
بحضرونا اليوم
بالسعوديه اول سؤال يتبادل الدهن كيف
عصرتي ورايتي التغيير الكبير اللي حصل في
الرياضه على مدار ثمان سنوات
[موسيقى]
مظبوط انا كنت هون من 2012 انا مستقره
بالرياض حاليا اييه طبعا كانت تغير كثير
كبير وكان يعني في فرق ملحوظ
واكيد هون بنشكر الامير محمد بن سلمان على
هالرؤيه الحلوه وعلى هالفكره الرائع يللي
خلى المواطنين والمقيمين يكونوا جدا
سعيدين بالمملكه مع كل الفعاليات اللي
قدموها همم هذا زياده انه خلوا العالم
يمني بره كمان تتحمس تيجي تشوف شو عم
بيصير بالمملكه وبالرياضيات تحديدا
والاهتمام بالفنون كان جزء من هذه الرؤيا
ايضا نتعشى انت قدمت كثير الاغاني
السعوديه منها الجديده ومنها الاغاني
الشعبي شو اكثر اغنيه قربتك للجمهور
السعودي
اول اغنيه عملتها داوني هي اكثر شيء ان
عرفت
بالبداياته
وبعدها لليوم تنطلب مني بحفلاته وبكل
الاشياء اللي بالنشاطات الفنيه اللي بيقوم
فيها وطبعا من بعدها في كثير ناس ما بتعرف
انه الخاتم يماني هي اغنيه الخاصه والحقوق
الكوفي يتبعها هي لالي
لاحنا فلكلور يا شعبان بس الكلمات كنا
باحدى الجلسات عم نعمل
هذا الكلام وسجلناه ومن بعدها صار في كثير
ناس كثير فنانين غنوه
ولا تحرف اخر اغنيه لالك كانت موجوده
انا حدا يلي ما بيعرفني اكيد اهل الاعراس
وزوجات يلي بتحبوني بيعرفوني وهذا اللي
بحمسهم اكتر انا حدا كثير اون تايم ااه بس
يكون بالزواج او بالحفلات بعامل اهل
الزواج كانهن اهلي
وهذا شيء بلاقيه بالمقابل كمان همم وطبعا
اكيد بقدم لهم الاغاني الحلوه اللي هم
بيحبوها وبنوع من اغانيه يعني اكيد بتغني
اغاني خاصه
حبيبه قلبي الفنانه احلام ام فهد اكيد
برجعلها تحيه كثير كبيره اول شيء بقولكم
انه انا بحبك يا انسانه لانه انسانه
انسانيتها عاليه جدا يلي ما بيعرفها شخصيا
عنجد بيجهلها اييه دعمتني ببداياتي وبعدها
لليوم تدعمني ودعمتني اكثر شيء باخر اغنيه
لتحرف
وانا الي الشرف وفخوره كثير انه هي ااا
حتى صوت من الاصوات الحلوه لانه عم بحضر
اخر شيء هلا اخر فتره سعودي
اكيد همم
عجبني فيها وجابني
دقيقه
بالملاحد فاكيد بفتخر بوجودك
يلا بغني لكم نتحرف
لا تحلفي كلامي على
مزاد
ولا تجولني بربك
شيء ما قلت
[موسيقى]
ها
كل مره
فرحك وابتهال
ارجع عند
معلمي لاجلك عمل
همم من عرفتك يا
منسيني السعاده
ما عرفت الفرحه
عايم فين كده كل ما حاولت اقول لك كم احبك
قلت شكلك ناوي القلب
بعده
الصبح
بوجودك معنا اليوم
انه يعني مش من زمان خلصنا من اجواء
المونديال واجواء الرياضه
نادي النصر السعودي واللاعب السعودي ماجد
عبد الله شو شو القصه
اه هاي عليها قديمه وعليه كتير عميقه ههه
انا بحبهن متابعتهن وشجعتهم من اول ما
اجيت على المملكه
وبتربطنا علاقه صداقه عائليه كبيره كثير
وبجله تحيه كثير كبيره للكابتن ماجد
عبدالله ايه يعني ما في ما في اثنين
بيختلفوا على حبهم لانه هيدا كانت نتفق صح
اكيد ههه
انا بحبه كتابه
[موسيقى]
هيئه الترفيه انا قدمت حفله باول ما بلشوه
بمركز الملك فهد الثقافي سنه 2019 كانت
حفله رائعه جدا
وانا بشكرن على هالساق وطبعا يعني بالنسبه
الفرس وان شاء الله يكون في فرصه ثانيه
انه يشارك معهم
وبحي زملاء الفنانين الي قدموا عمل جدا
رائع على المسيح بكل المواسم اللي همم
لليوم صارت واكيد بنشكر معالي المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ على اهل الجهود الحلوه
ومنقله استمر ونحنا بحاجه له فعاليات
الحلوه اللي عم بتقدمها واكيد بتمنى ان
يكون لي فرصه ان يكون معكم ونحن كسبنا
كمان هاي الفرصه انك تكوني معنا في صباح
العربيه